welcome to screen junkies summer
blockbusters are in full effect
our good friend of the show Nick Mundy
has been texting and e-mailing like a
maniac
wanting to come on talk about Man of
Steel and obviously since the movie has
been out for three weeks spoilers ahead
duh
Nick apparently you did not care for
this movie look I love Superman I've
been wanting a good Superman my entire
life I've never gotten it so when Man of
Steel was announced I got excited and
then when the trailers came out hey look
King awesome and then I watched it and
it was like holy [ __ ]
this isn't even a Superman movie I mean
he destroys metropolis he murders Zod
and they just ripped off every movie
went for Terrence Malick to the Avengers
to stee matrix if you want to rip off a
movie why do you rip off Superman cries
all right then today we have with us an
opposing viewpoint a man who loved the
film a good friend of ours the writer of
torso Manhunter and Captain America
comics please welcome mr. mark and Draco
hi Hal hi mark
so you really liked Man of Steel I did I
thought it was a very good film so mark
can you rebut some of Nick's points Oh
gladly gladly how can you say that this
isn't a good Superman movie he saves
people he gets a great costume
he meets Lois Lane there's the Daily
Planet all the elements of Superman are
in there did Superman year one this is
his first mission and he has to save the
planet Zod's never gonna stop killing
him is the responsible thing to do and
yes it does take a part of his soul
we're gonna explore the know killing
Superman in the sequel well maybe he
would have learned not to kill if Paul
Kent wasn't such a dick in the beginning
of the movie what was I supposed to do
just that I'm dying maybe
he had this cold alien father and then
he had cold alien kevin costner father
he's nothing called an alien about Kevin
Costner kind of Kevin Costner and of
itself is called an alien no I'll give
you that but in his movie he was
fantastic guys clearly you disagree
let's get specific now Nick you thought
there were several plot holes in the
movie yeah there were more plot holes in
this movie than any movie I've seen in a
long time okay they have this world
engine that could terraform earth into
Krypton but if they do that they would
lose their powers that makes no sense
one you just be king of heart if I if I
dodged powers I would be like hey you
know what fine we'll just take her earth
and it'll be fine
and I'll be king of the mountain and
I'll actually actually you proved my
point with why Superman needed to kill
Zod because I was going to destroy earth
or be the ruler of it so Superman had to
destroy him to save the people of Earth
also it showed up how also why was
Superman's ship why would Superman suit
in the ship when it was already
established that that was 20,000 years
later
and speaking of ships why did Louis have
to go up to Gerald they didn't need it
was it like seriously Fleur exposition
cuz that's the only thing I can figure
out and then also why does everyone in
Smallville know that Clark Kent is
Superman uh how can we get some oxygen
for him and can I respond to some of
that that I remember no oxygen for him
yes you can respond first of all you
brought up the thing about people in
Smallville knowing how Superman is which
is something I like I also like the fact
that Lois Lane knew who he was because
the whole concept of super-secret
identities is a leftover from the
McCarthy era oh yeah okay cuz yeah
secret identities with the NSA are
needed right now so like yeah no that's
that's completely untimely yeah that
does this are you auditioning to be a
little rush limbaugh for Fox News come
down the thing that was great about the
people of Smallville knowing who Clark
was that's an alt that's a
quintessentially American moment they
knew who he was they will never tell
anyone outside their community and Lois
knowing who he is it makes perfect sense
because the biggest problem with Lois
Lane is a character throughout the
history of Superman is she's this
Pulitzer Prize winning brilliant
fearless investigative journalist and
she gets you through a pair of glasses
it makes her a [ __ ] idiot guys if I
could chime in I found the film to be
among other things uh Turley humorless
Emirate I have to remain impartial
mark where do you stand on the tone of
the movie I would rather have it err on
the side of humor lessness
and on the
can't be ridiculous crap I don't
disagree with you you know I don't want
like that to exist in a Superman movie
either but the problem was they wanted
to Dark Knight the Superman but there
are two different characters like
Superman's about hope Batman's about
fear it just felt like Dark Knight Rises
where everything sucks
everything's miserable it doesn't need
to be like funny ha ha hilarious it
doesn't need to be Tony Stark but it
should be uplifting did you feel
uplifted after the end of a Man of Steel
at least in the Dark Knight I think
there are even more uplifting who felt
hopeful out of this and at the end of
this movie
wait a minute you're saying the Dark
Knight was hopeful it was all based on a
lie ok we're really starting to digress
here so a lot of good points but let me
remind both of you there was one huge
funny moment where that girl said oh
he's hot I'm just kidding that wasn't
funny that's cuz it's true I would kiss
Henry Cavill let's get back to Superman
was Man of Steel too dark yes Superman
is supposed to be the symbol of oak the
people of Metropolis and Earth never saw
Superman as this heroic guy who saved
them Superman saved one person by my
count he told a person in the Smallville
fight hey
go into that IHOP it's dangerous out
here
then he [ __ ] threw one of the giant
Kryptonian people into the IHOP probably
killing him you gotta admit that was
some great integration for IHOP I mean I
hop had more screen time than Laurence
Fishburne not to mention Nokia Vizio and
Sears and and but that's that's not the
point the point is the movie had
absolutely no hope whatsoever I think in
a lot of ways you need to look as man of
steel is the first act of a larger movie
because there was so much heavy lifting
they have to do to rehabilitate the
Superman mythos I've met no one that
thinks Superman was just okay people
either love it or they hate it the fact
that we're having this conversation is
proof that they did something right guys
some great points
let's talk sequel what do we want to see
in the next Man of Steel movie I think
Brainiac is what I want to say and
Brainiac and the introduction of Lex
Luthor it'll be great to see Lex Luthor
portrayed as a villain on screen for the
first time as opposed to a bumbling fool
hopefully that's the way they do it and
another way they can set it up the movie
is like no one trusts Superman so they
can have Lex Luthor as like this like
social media billionaire just run this
like speed campaign against
Superman turning the people of Earth
even more against Superman
while Luthor's doin villains and then
Superman gets up that's the only way
they could do it my problem the problem
is I think they're going to be like it
made so much money doing it the one way
of just the disaster porn that they're
just going to do that and they've been
wanting to do doomsday sees what the
first over the fact that the viewing
audience for this movie is so split and
it's such an extreme divide means I
think they're gonna actually listen
because it all Nolan also said he didn't
want Superman to kill Zod and originally
he this later had to convince him of
that which what in world do we live in
where Zack Snyder convinces Christopher
Nolan to do something a world of
compromise which gentlemen I'd like to
do here let's compromise and agree to
disagree shake hands great listening to
both you guys let me ask you who did you
agree with who did you be Emily disagree
with and what movie disappointed you the
most so far this summer let us know in
the comments below best answer boys gets
a screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
my pals Nick Mundy and Mark and Draco
it's been a wild ride thanks for
watching screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick
my bike